j'ai reçu un mail ce matin un job d'été
il te payerait 2500 dollars par jour
c'est pas les détails mais c'est pas
n'importe qui mais certainement être
Jackson vous devez être Ethan faisons un
test pratique et voyons où vous en êtes
nous attendons
un garçon
je
t'aime
que fait votre père je n'ai pas le droit
de vous le dire
et sinon votre mère
[Musique]
comment se passe ton travail le gosse me
donne l'impression oui
d'être dans un monde bizarre ce sont que
des enfants Ethan l'argent a toujours
fait partie d'eux et même s'ils sont un
peu perturbés à propos du bébé vous
l'avez désiré
savez-vous pour le bébé
le CD par moi dans leur seulement total
je suis Annie est Amina beaucoup parlé
de vous devez être une personne très
spéciale vous allez devoir y mettre un
terme
vous êtes accusé d'avoir agressé Jackson
c'est Jackson qui s'est donné des coups
tout seul j'ai besoin de ce boulot j'ai
un bébé qui arrive il faut que je
raccroche vous avez passé une bonne
soirée j'ai tout perdu à cause de vous
et n'approchez pas de ma famille où je
vous ferai du mal
[Musique]